ket a0에요. 그래서 ZF 연산을 없앨 수 있어요. 이제 위에 있는
ket u의 설명과 ket a0과 ket A1이 직교 단위 벡터라는 사실을 사용해서
여기 bra와 ket의 곱을 계산할 수 있어요. 그러면 비해의 수를
n으로 나눈 제곱근을 얻어요. 이 사실을 이용해 결과를 평가하고, ket u의 표현을 대입해서
단순화하면 화면에 표시된 최종 결과를 얻어요. 특히 이
벡터는 앞서 제안한 것처럼 ket a0과 ket A1이 생성하는 2차원 부분공간에 포함돼요.
게다가 계수들은 항상 실수예요. 원하신다면
본인 속도에 맞게 검증해 보세요. 저는 이런 것들을 영상에서 빠르게 넘어가는 편인데,
원하시면 영상을 일시 정지하고 생각해 보시길 기대하면서요. 자, 나중을 위해 최종 결과를 정리해 봐요.
이제 나중에 사용할 최종 결과를 저장해요. 그리고 이제 벡터 ket
A1에 대해서도 비슷한 걸 할 거예요. 전과 같은 G의 표현을 사용할 수 있고, 이번에는 ZF gate가
마이너스 부호를 넣어요. 여기서는 괄호 안의 두 항을 교환한 것으로 반영돼요.
그다음 매우 비슷한 방식으로 진행하면 두 계수가
교환되고 그 중 하나 앞에 마이너스 부호가 붙는다는 점을 제외하면 비슷한 최종 결과를 얻어요. 이건 대수학이 풀리는 방식이에요.
역시 본인 속도에 맞게 확인해 보실 수 있어요. 다시 한번 두 벡터 ket a0과
ket A1의 실수 선형 조합을 얻어요. 이걸도 정리하고 다른 것과 합쳐서 놓을게요. 이제 G가
두 벡터가 생성하는 부분공간에 어떻게 작용하는지 볼 수 있어요. 한 가지 방법은 화면에 표시된
2×2 행렬 M으로 표현하는 거예요. 여기서 하는 건 첫 번째 행과 첫 번째
열을 ket a0에, 두 번째 행과 열을 ket A1에 연결하는 거예요. 이 시리즈에서 지금까지는
행렬을 주로 연산이 표준 기저 상태에서 작동하는 방식을 설명하는 데 사용했지만, 행렬을 사용해서
선형 맵의 표준 기저 상태가 아닌 다른 벡터 집합에 대한 작용을 설명하는 건 일반적이에요. 여기서는 G 연산이
벡터 ket a0과 ket A1에 무엇을 하는지 이야기하고 있어요. ket a0과 ket A1의 생성 공간에 있는 벡터들에게 G가 무엇을 하는지
더 자세히 알 수 있는데, 이 행렬 M을 더 자세히 살펴보면요. 특히 발견하게 될 건
M이 회전 행렬이라는 거예요. 즉 이 2차원 공간에서의 작용이 어떤 고정된 각도만큼의 회전으로 설명될 수 있어요.
이걸 볼 수 있는 방법이 몇 가지 있는데, 하나는
이 행렬 M이 좀 더 간단해 보이는 행렬의 제곱으로 표현될 수 있다는 걸 관찰하는 거예요. M만 보면 발견하기 어려울 수 있는데,
우리가 스스로 발견해야 할 필요는 없어요. 검증하기만 하면 되고, 단순히
오른쪽 행렬을 제곱함으로써 할 수 있어요. 제곱을 포함하지 않고 오른쪽 행렬을 쓰는 또 다른 방법은
화면에 표시돼 있어요. 이게 주어진 각도 Theta만큼의 회전을
행렬로 설명하는 일반적인 방법이에요. 우리가 회전하는 정확한 각도는 해의 수를
n으로 나눈 것의 제곱근의 역사인이에요. 참고로 처음 보시는 거니까
이 각도가 매우 중요하다는 걸 지적할게요. 이 분석을 계속하면서
계속 나타날 거예요. 역사인의 인수는 0과 1 사이의 수이고, 특히 여기서
역사인을 해석하는 방식은 사인을 취했을 때 인수를 주는 0과 π/2 사이의 각도예요.
그러니까 그게 M을 얻기 위해 제곱한 행렬을 생각하는 한 가지 방법이에요.
그리고 행렬을 제곱하는 건 두 번 적용하는 것과 같으니까, M이 theta가 아닌 2*theta만큼 회전으로 대안적으로 쓰여질 수 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
제곱함으로써 theta 각도만큼 두 번
회전하는 거니까요. 참고로 도움이 된다면 이 모든 걸 검증하는 다른 방법은 M의 이 최종 표현에서 시작해서
삼각법의 이중 각도 공식을 사용해서 M의 원래 표현을
얻는 거예요. 그리고 이게 ket a0과 ket A1이 생성하는 부분공간에 g가 하는 작용을 설명하는 M의 표현이에요.
앞으로 가장 유용할 거예요. 이제 Grover의 알고리즘 자체로 돌아가서, 초기화 단계 후
하지만 G를 적용하기 전에 n qubit 레지스터 Q의 상태는 ket u예요. 즉
모든 n비트 문자열에 대한 균등 중첩이에요. 여기 ket a0과 ket
A1로 표현한 ket u의 같은 표현이 있어요. 하지만 이제 이 각도 Theta를 확인했으니
ket u를 cosine(Theta) * ket a0 + sin(Theta) * ket
A1로 대안적으로 쓸 수 있어요. ket A1의 계수는 명확하고, 다른 계수는 a0의 크기와
A1의 크기의 합이 n이라는 걸 관찰한 후 기본 삼각법으로 얻을 수 있어요. 그게 시작 상태이고,
G를 처음 적용하면 2*Theta 각도만큼 회전해서 총 각도가 3*
Theta가 돼요. G를 다시 적용하면 추가로 2Theta만큼 회전했으니 각도가 5Theta로 증가해요.
이런 식으로요. 그래서 G를 T번 적용하면 화면에 표시된 것처럼
상태를 나타낼 수 있어요. 상태의 각도는 (2T+1)*Theta예요. G를 각각 적용할 때마다 2*Theta이고,
시작 상태가 Theta였으니까 추가로 Theta가 더해지는 거예요.
Grover 연산의 작용을 기하학적으로도 생각해 볼 수 있어요. 이게 어떻게 작동하는지,
왜 레지스터 Q의 상태를 회전시키는지에 대한 빛을 비춰줘요. 주요 아이디어는 Grover
연산이 이미 확인한 두 부분의 조합이라는 거예요. 하나는 ZF이고, 다른 하나는 두 레이어의
Hadamard gate 사이에 끼워진 z or이에요. 이 두 부분은
반사이고, 두 반사를 합성하면 회전을 얻어요. 이게 어떻게 작동하는지
더 자세히 살펴봐요. 먼저 ZF에 집중해요. 그리고 우리가 이야기해온 같은
2차원 부분공간, 즉 ket a0과 ket
A1이 생성하는 부분공간으로 주의를 제한할게요. 이미 관찰했듯이, ZF가 이 공간에서 하는 작용은 꽤 간단해요.
ket a0에는 아무것도 하지 않고 ket A1 앞에 마이너스 부호를 붙여요. 이건 반사이고, 특히